Hi guys, my name is Heinrich
and welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
Today I'd like to talk
about the little things,
the little things that
may not seem important
at first sight, but can
really make a difference
how you are perceived in
your work environment.
Personally, I like to call
these things hygiene factors.
So if you wonder what a hygiene factor is,
let's think about a great hotel.
It is super luxurious,
a great entrance hall
you have a personal Butler,
who brings to your food,
your luggage and everything
else you may need.
So at firsthand, it might
seem that this is just
an amazing experience
and a great day to be it
and actually imagine the following thing;
you're going to the bathroom
and you'll find the toilet
not being cleaned their hairs
of potentially previous guests
in your shower and adjust
does not seem clean
and nice as you would expect.
What would be the impression
of this hotel now?
But for sure, nevermind all
the great Butler services
and luxurious wines and great
luxurious entrance halls
your experience, your
impression of that hotel
will be over and this is due to something
that is called hygiene factors.
These are factors that if
they are there by themselves,
they do not make a great impression
but if they're not there
anymore of their gun,
then this is super bad and your customer,
your professional, your work colleague,
we just have a very bad impression of you.
Just as the hygiene and hotel,
the hotel may be as great as this might be
but if the toilet, the
bathroom is not hygienic,
then adjust the bad hotel.
And there's similar things like that,
in the workplaces where
there are these little things
that if you do them, that
by itself will not be great.
Nobody will say hey, this Tony guy,
he's so great because
he's doing these things.
But if you don't do them,
then that actually might be
perceived as unprofessional
as not knowing the rules of the game
is just not being proud of the culture,
just not knowing how to behave in a good
and professional manner,
and you don't want that.
So let's go over five things like that,
that are little things,
but I believe really make a difference.
And these are some lessons
that I really learned
from my time at McKinsey,
where these things
are just perceived to be super basic,
you just need to follow these
kind of professional standards,
but this is not just to focus on dieting,
this is true for other
industry firms like that,
where these things are just important
and you do not want to stand out
by not doing these things right.
So let's start with five
tips that really make
a difference in the
workplace and that you should
just get right in order to not
be perceived in a negative way.
The first step is about
how you write your emails.
And let me start with a little story here.
A friend of mine recently started working
with a large venture capital
fund here in Germany.
And he told me the story and
I just thought it was funny
so let me just share it because
when he was kind of applying
for the job and getting
those first interviews,
of course, the tone was super friendly,
he was writing this email
and getting these super nice
and friendly responses and so on.
And then suddenly after he got hired,
and kind of he wrote the very
first email in the same style,
he was always writing
them, and the first reply
he got from this direct supervisors,
and let's just call this
guy Tony, "Please, Tony,
from now on only and bullet points,
I only want to have
emails in bullet points."
And this might sound a
bit stupid and ridiculous
but I think this is really
to the point and important.
In work life, nobody wants
to read two paragraphs
of text of lots and lots of
words of super long email
of a page longer and so on, nobody wants
to read these kind of emails.
If you write an email, make sure that
it's written in bullet points,
at least always if it goes kind of beyond
a couple of sentences.
But if you have several
thoughts that you want to share,
never just write text, but
rather than bullet points,
each bullet point consists
of one argument, one thought,
one point that you want to bring forward,
be concise, be to the point,
don't write fluff in your emails,
make it crisp and clear what you want.
And this is just helpful to
everybody because otherwise,
you are just a waste of time.
Nobody wants to do that, nobody wants
to read these kind of super long emails.
My second tip also regards to emails
but not what you write them down
but rather documents
attachments that you do.
You see super frequently in businesses,
the people are sending raw attachments
with the name of something
like COPY OF COPY OF ATTACHMENT-597. XLSX
or something like that.
So basically you have an
attachment with a name
that has just not been edited,
that just has been exported,
copied from whatever other program
and you don't have a keyword
I was in the attachment
just by reading the name.
Guys this is just super unprofessional,
you cannot protect that
you cannot just send
these attachments with these
gibberish names like that.
I mean, imagine all these
people needing to drag
and drop your attachment
maybe in their file structure
and they're file system
and all the need for first
look into it and then to give it a name,
how much more convenient
would it be to everybody,
if just you from the beginning
would have given a clear
and crisp name to that attachment,
that basically the
person would direct know
what is in the file, but
then could just drag the file
in his own file system
without needing to edit it
or to do any other
changes to the file name.
Be professional, name
your attachments in a way
that makes sense guys, otherwise,
it's just unprofessional.
Don't do that, don't be
that guy, do it this way
and you'll be just fine.
Third point is about your availability.
And here of course, the
culture might be different
from business to business.
So this may be not related
to your specific business
to your specific organization,
but from my experiences
is something that is
just very well received
and widely appreciated.
And situations are you available,
if your colleague, your
team leader or supervisor
or another person you work
with wants to reach out to you
and especially via phone.
And personally, in my organization
where I currently work,
I know two or three people,
if I try to call them,
I just know that they will
not pick up at that moment.
They are just not available on the phone,
I will not be able to know
just call them and reach them
and this is just annoying.
Maybe I just want to talk
about something with them
I would like to discuss a thought I have,
there's something maybe
super urgent and important
I'd like to address but these people
are just not approachable
and that's the problem.
And an organization's would
usually tend to happen
is that these people actually are called
less frequently than others,
they are considered less
than other colleagues.
If I want to know something
want to discuss something
I rather call the guy
who I know will pick up
and will let me know what's going on
and if you have some time
for me, or maybe later.
But if you are the guy who
never picks up his phone,
maybe even doesn't want to
because he feels bothered,
feels like this is not the best
use of my time or whatever,
I will just not reach
out these people anymore.
And in the short term,
this might be nice helpful,
you might feel like you have
more time to do other things,
but in the long term, this will
really hurt your reputation
and your standing organization.
So do not do that.
And what I would advise, always make sure
if somehow possible to pick up
and if you do not have time at the moment,
just let the guy know, sorry,
right now is not a good time,
let me call you later,
let's call this evening,
let's have a call tomorrow.
If you really cannot pick
up the phone right now
than at least directly
write a short text and say,
"Sorry, can talk about now
we're recording later."
But be responsive, answer
let the other person know
what is going on and how she can reach you
because usually if somebody calls you
there's something important
that the person wants to discuss.
So don't just flake, don't
just tuck away from the corner
but take it and make sure you're reachable
for the important people
in your organization.
The fourth tip is about
how you handle meetings
and meeting invites.
And sure, this might also
depend on the organization
and maybe at your place,
it's very different than some
but usually what what I observed
what is widely appreciated
almost all organizations is
making good use of calendar invites of
your outlook invite, calendar system
or the ICAL system, or
whatever you might use,
but make use of that.
So if you have a meeting,
make it a good habit of yours
of always sending out a calendar invite
to make sure that that person
directly has it in their calendar.
Because usually what will
happen and this person needs
to make the invite the
entry into calendar himself,
which of course takes
time and is annoying,
and especially if you're
hosting larger meetings
with more than only one counterpart
and every person needs
to do that by himself,
instead of you just doing
it once and then everybody
has a direct in the calendar.
And of course, there are other
benefits to that as well,
if you reschedule it,
everybody directly sees it.
What you should of course,
also do is always enter
a location, if it's kind of out of office,
enter the exact address
where the other person
is supposed to go to just
enter the name of the hotel
or the name of the conference room
that you would like to go to
because it's just very annoying
and completely unprofessional
if the person just find that
and then it's to look it
up on Google or somewhere,
just to know where you
actually intend to meet.
And especially now imagine a situation
where you sit in a car, maybe
have your phone connected
to the navigation system,
you expect that the invite
has this info click on your
calendar, you open the invite,
and then just to find
that you cannot just click
on the address and it
will directly guide you
in the navigation to go there
which you would have expected
and you wouldn't have fall for
but now that you just
find the name of the hotel
that now you need to independently
google and look out for.
I mean, again, guys, this is annoying,
this is unprofessional.
Don't be that guy, don't do that.
Always send out invites to make it easier
for everybody who's
supposed to participate
and then also make sure that all
the relevant meeting
information is actually included
in this invite to make the
life easier for everybody
who's involved.
Now to my tip number five,
and this is about how
you actually handle meetings.
And one thing that I
believe is really crucial,
but that many people don't do
is setting up proper agendas.
If you set up a meeting,
if you invite somebody,
maybe even just the colleague,
you would like to talk
to about a few topics,
always make sure that in the invite,
or in the email that you
write them in advance,
they are kind of in a bullet style format,
the things that you would like to talk,
the things that you would like to address.
You know, meetings are just super annoying
if there's no invite, nobody really knows
what it's supposed to be all about,
nobody has an understanding
what the outcomes
are supposed to be of the meeting
and then you're sitting in the meeting
with the meeting organizer,
and often even the organizer himself
hasn't clearly thought that out
and then very often this meeting
are just completely unproductive.
So again, please do your
very best to prepare,
let the other person know
what the meeting is supposed
to be all about to also give
the other person a chance
to prepare for himself,
'cause then the likelihood
of the meeting being a
success and yielding results
that are valuable for everybody
and being a good investment
of time for everybody involved
are just much higher.
Do that and everybody will
be happy and you will just
create a much more professional experience
in your organization.
So let me just to recap, five tips today,
little tips, little things,
where I believe though
that these things really
make a difference.
First is about how you write emails.
Make sure that then the bullet form type,
write bullet points,
don't write long text,
nobody wants to read long email.
Second point, make sure that you name
your attachments properly,
that people can just pick up
the attachment know what's
in, can directly stored
in the whole file system,
without any trouble anything
that's just kind of
annoying and nobody knows
what's in there.
Third to this your availability.
Make sure that people can reach you.
If you're calling pick up or
at least write a short text
letting the person know that
right now is not a good time
but you are of course
happy to reach out later.
Be available to the important
people in your organization.
Fourth is about how you
handle meeting invites.
Make sure that you always
send such an invite,
and make sure that all
the relevant information
is included in it, especially
the location of course,
also for instance, dial in information
for telephone conference,
anything like that.
And last but not least, meeting agendas.
If you talk to somebody set up a meeting
with an individual or
a group, make sure that
you let know the people in advance
what is expected of
them, what the agenda is,
what you hope to get out of the meeting.
Five things you may believe
these are the little things
and you're right they are
and probably if you do that,
it's not like everybody
would walk around and say
this Tony guy is the greatest guys of all.
But if you don't do these things,
with a high likelihood this
will fall back negatively on you.
It's like a hygiene factor,
it's like the toilet
that is not cleaned up
properly, get that right
and make a good thing out of that.
Thank you guys, think you a lot.
So guys, thank you for watching
this new episode of Firm Learning.
If you enjoyed it, I
would very much appreciate
if you could just subscribe
below to the channel,
I have many more content pieces lined up
for in the next weeks and month.
I would love you to be
there and listen to that.
Of course if you have any
comments, any feedback,
let me know also write in
the comment section below,
I'd love that.
Have a good day and
thank you for watching.